[Music]
my name is jungkoo i
normally live in hong kong but this year
i'm here in berlin because
i'm the artist in residence at the
gropius bell
i'm not a scientist i'm an artist my
primary concern these years is the
climate crisis and also i would call the
the extinction crisis
i think in order to address these really
planetary crisis
as artists i have to work with
scientists but i also work with
people in humanities in social science
et cetera because i think it's you know
in order to address these large issues
is really something we have to come
together from all the disciplines
[Music]
here i'm doing two things
every day i spend some time with plants
i do a drawing so it could be
it could be weeds here on the ground or
it could be a tree
because i i i think it's it's a daily
practice it's a
it's a it's something that i do every
day
i think i get into um
the habit of spending time with other
species
with other beings often without
resorting to language i think this is
very important so i can
really sense the existence the way of
life of other beings the other thing i
do
in berlin is to actually to talk to
scientists
because i you know i'm interested in how
scientists
study plants what they have learned
about plants and often you know they not
only study plants they also study plants
and bacteria plants and fungi et cetera
so i'm learning from the scientists
they're
i'm learning from their research i'm in
conversation with them to kind of
think about how we can see plants
differently
how we can understand their existence
not only as biological but
also as political because we tend to see
our
life as not only a biological existence
right we have social life we have
you know we we get in we get we fall
into love
we build communities we vote uh
in some places we vote we govern
we tend not to see plants in that way so
i'm
in these conversations i'm trying to
learn from the scientists and also
develop some ideas how we can also see
plants as political existence
[Music]
i grew up on the edge of beijing
so so i'm so i live on one street and on
this side of the street
is the city and the other side of the
street is
slow i mean low mountains
so i used to kind of play in both areas
you know i would go into the city but
i'll also go
to the to the woods
i think that somehow that early
experience sort of made me
uh interested in both things you know
i'm interested in plants but i'm also
interested in politics
and i always say because i grew up in
beijing beijing is a highly political
city
if i get into the city there's food i
mean it's full of political symbols
kind of like east berlin but if i go to
the woods you know there are these
you know old trees but also
farming areas and also weeds
so it's a very different existence but
it's you know it's right next to each
other
so i think that that's kind of how i'm
doing things now
actually try to link these two sides
[Music]
because of the coronavirus i came a bit
later than
i was going to but
you know given the very short time i've
been here i
realized you know first of all it's a
very political city too
[Music]
the political i mean the recent
political history
is depressing but also fascinating
on the other hand you know i'm studying
here there are lots of trees in the city
it's the museum is right next to the
garden i you know i rode
my bike this morning here through the
garden
it feels like a little forest
you know it's been there for my standing
it's been there for over 100 years
i also go to swim in a small lake close
to where i live
so i've learned that um berlin is
or used to be a city with lakes
so i'm trying to understand where i'm
trying to sense
the politics of the city the uh
the nature in the city but also the you
know the geological history
of the city and then you know there are
many universities in berlin
you know the reason i decided to come
here do this project to talk to
scientists really because this is
kind of one of the major
research centers in the world there are
many
scientists who study plants
fungi bacteria as i said yes
[Music]
there are two aspects so one is we
in our political life we have always
[Music]
used plants for example where i live in
hong kong
the symbol of hong kong is a bohemian
flower
i always think it's funny because
the bohemian flower the the bohemian
plant
was an accident and it cannot reproduce
on its own so it actually needs
humans to populate this plant
so you could say it's a good symbol
because it shows our relationship
to that particular plant but
in the as the other aspect i'm trying to
develop developing my art practice and
research
is really to see the existence of plants
as political i think
many people probably have either read or
heard
the relationship between trees so
trees actually connect underground
if if they're in a forest they connect
underground with the
the fungi network so information is sent
between trees and also nutritions are
exchanged between tree roots and the
fungi network
we could see this as a biological
phenomenon
but we could also see this as community
building right
so you have two you have two
species or two kingdoms where they
form relationships you could call that
diplomacy
right if we treat these two kingdoms as
nations
or we could use other terms we could
call them racial relations we could call
them tribal relations so if we
start to see plants
in this light i think perhaps we can
learn
from them how they practice politics
whether we can learn to practice
politics better
and then the next thing is how do we
practice politics
together with plants right if they
already build communities
when we think about building our
communities it shouldn't
be just human only it should be
you know all existing beings on
this planet so i think that will expand
our notion of politics
[Music]
so i think i'm very early in this
thinking and practicing research
so i've done some works for example i've
done one
installation
we replanted a political slogan
the slogan was socialism good
so in beijing on
october 1st our national day we always
have
large floral designs on tierment square
the center of the city
in 1991 i was in high school the design
on tiananmen square was
socialism good it's a slogan made of
flowers
so i i recreated this
installation but the the second time is
a few years ago
the second time we planted the flowers
in the in the soil and after the
installation was finished we didn't
intervene
so the plants would grow but also weeds
will grow
right so you know when we don't
intervene as humans
the diversity will actually increase in
certain
situations so we started to grow and
then they interrupted the
slogan so this is one way to suggest
that perhaps we should think about
how do we incorporate plants
when we think about socialism if we
think socialism good
do we also allow weeds to
sort of enjoy or participate in this
political idea
but this is very early i think this is a
very early
work you know i'm talking to scientists
now to
to think about to really learn how
to interpret the behavior
the physiology of plants so i think
probably the word
my work will change
[Music]
i'm not a scientist so i'm in in the in
the
event it will be conversations between
me as an artist
with uh plant scientists
i think the conversation is very
important because we have very different
approaches
like i said every day i spend time with
plants i draw them
right for me it's not doing experiment
is to be with plants to really spend
time with plants to
to sense their existence to
really live with them i think scientists
also live with their plants
but they often have very
clear hypothesis
or sort of quantitative measures
they also perhaps would do some
experiments in some control situations
so i think the the the relationships are
quite different
i think for scientists they
can learn things in a very focused way
in a very targeted way in a very short
time they will understand
very specific behaviors of plants i
think for me
spending time with plants it's not to
understand specific behaviors but to
to kind of sense their overall existence
so i think these two are quite different
but
i think we can complement each other
that's why i think the conversations
will be important
[Music]
i like some plants perhaps more than
other plants but i mean i like all the i
like all
living beings but perhaps you know i
spent more time i
a few years ago i started to spend more
time with ferns in taiwan
but i think in berlin there are firms
but they're not so
abundant so i'm learning to spend more
time with trees
i think there are more trees in the city
um
actually taller bigger trees than where
i live in hong kong
so i'm taking advantage of the time here
to spend more time with trees
and you know i also worked with weeds i
worked with
ferns i haven't really worked with trees
i think for me i kind of wanted to wait
because trees are massive you know
they also live hundreds of years so it
takes
probably some preparation from my side
to be
ready to really spend time with them but
i'm really enjoying the trees in the
city yes
i think it's more like being spend time
with plants
spend time with plants and also
trying to go beyond just see them as
food or decoration
really pay attention to their
existence to their ways of life
because i i think even for many
scientists their research
is to make plants useful
in for medicine
for agriculture
for urban ecology
so i'm you know i'm interested in how
they can be
useful in this political sense in this
way that we could actually live better
on the planet so
i think i'm not i'm i'm actually moving
away from
just looking at individual plants
i'm really interested in relations
between plants between plants and
bacteria between plants
and insects etc and also between plants
and nuts
because it's you know i still use the
word
species but perhaps i should stop using
it because
you know species individuals these are
quite
sort of inward looking term words
i'm interested in relations in
cohabitation in communities
in commoning so these words are more
important
[Music]
it will be a series of three
conversations
in one day so the first conversation
will be
here at the gropius bound and we want
and then the second conversation will
walk to the tear garden because i think
there we will actually be surrounding
plant plants
and then we'll come back to the group
he's about to have a group discussion
all three conversations will center
on this idea of how do we imagine
how do we understand and imagine
the politics of plants i think this is
probably
a question that not many people have
thought about i think
most scientists i'm talking to they have
some inclinations but i don't think in
their research they will frame this
as their research question so i think
the conversations
really is to start to think about this
issue i think we will talk about
specific research that these scientists
are doing now you know for for example
um
plasticity and adaptation
and the relations between plants and
bacteria
but i think we will not have a sort of
conclusive
answer to this question is really to
start the conversation
[Applause]
[Music]
you